will and Chad last week I asked you to
leave your homes to view black panther
wakanda forever you must now discuss
your astonishing experiences of
literally going to the actual movies for
real this is literally going to the
actual movies for real begin
um black panther wakanda forever when
did the first black panther come out do
you know a couple years ago all right
sounds good it was a massive success I
broke all kinds of box office records
obviously
um Chadwick Boseman played Black Panther
in that and then he tragically died from
cancer which he kept a secret from
everybody and so that was one of the big
kind of uh question marks for the sequel
was how the [ __ ] are they going to deal
with the fact that the star of their
movie
foreign
I hope you can hear that and I hope you
thought at the very beginning of that
that it was Chad finally farting which
he will never do on the show but I'm
getting you ready no yeah I will never
fart I I try to never fart in another
human being's presence it's rare that I
even have to fart but when I do oh give
me a [ __ ] wall you don't fart I do
oh I said it was rare I do it's not rare
but I I do try to you're full of gruel
you don't fart all the time I have
pretty much perfect control over my uh
inner body oh now that's still wonderful
to be uh odor free yeah it's great as
Del Griffith says in in plain strains
and Automobiles which is the movie you
should be watching on Thanksgiving but
we digress so one of the big question
marks was how are they going to handle
Chadwick Boseman no longer being with us
yes
how they handled that was
by making a two hour and 40 minute movie
that opens with what I think is about a
10 minute uh funeral sequence that is
sad as [ __ ] so the whole tone of the
movie is now kind of sad kind of
depressed and there are spoilers in this
so if you haven't seen this movie
spoiler alert now you're going to want
to uh fast forward maybe 10-15 minutes
I'm not sure how long we're gonna talk
about this but
not only is is that what happens in the
beginning so all the characters in the
movie are now sad no one is having a
good time that's true everyone in the
movie is just crying and they can't
believe this has happened and rightly so
this is a tragic incident however you
know this is a movie a fictional movie
about comic book characters so I was
hoping that you know maybe it wouldn't
be as sad as it was but it was
incredibly sad then we move on into the
movie and a major character dies this is
a another the spoiler this is what I'm
telling you now fast forward if you
don't want to hear this
um Angela bassett's character the queen
of wakanda winds up getting killed in
the course of the movie so now all these
characters who are super sad are now
super sad again they doubled down on the
sorrow right in the middle of this
[ __ ] movie yeah dude it was hard when
you're sad dude that's an emotion
brother yeah that's something you feel
inside dude and that's what we want the
audience to feel during something like
WrestleMania 3 where I slaying that
ain't giant right through the map in
Pontiac Michigan in the Pontiac
Silverton okay foreign
Maniacs dude but then when Angela
Bassett dies dude then you're more sad
dude and that is a different emotion
brother yeah dude I also thought there
was a a kind of narrative problem within
the beginning Angela Bassett once
um Chadwick boseman's character t'challa
his little sister uh she wants her to
take up the mantle she's the princess of
wakanda to become the next Black Panther
and she doesn't want to do it uh at
first out of kind of just like personal
reasons but also they kind of failed to
address the point that you have to have
this magic flower you have to eat this
magic flower to become black panther
which no longer exists because Michael B
Jordan's character burned them all up in
the the prior movie but at any rate she
eventually does obviously become Black
Panther and they fight Namor who is one
of my favorite
uh Marvel characters of all time I
remember there was was that based on a
comic book character yeah
all the Marvel movies are based on the
comics I know it's just a Marvel comic
books yeah so they wouldn't just come up
with other stuff to put in there not big
characters like that they make up some
little like supporting characters here
and there you know but not like no name
Wars a a big character of the Marvel
Universe
um for a stint when I was a kid Jay Lee
was doing the art for Neymar [ __ ]
mind-blowing still some of the coolest
art that's ever been done in comics of
my humble opinion this is the problem
that I have with these comic book movies
you got to eat some [ __ ] flower and
that just takes care of everything lazy
writing if you ask me and let's we'll
add some new [ __ ] characters that are
fun speaking of yeah uh what'd you think
of this movie I'll I'll get to that
Planes Trains and Automobiles is the
Thanksgiving movie that you want to see
uh if you're and as I've said on other
podcasts uh yeah I've said if you are
not reduced to a uh a sobbing mess at
the end of playing trains non-mobile you
are a soulless meat puppet just uh like
what you think that's what I am human
beings are well uh that's what I am
in in Planes trades and Automobiles
there's many funny tertiary characters
like the guy who uh Picks Them Up and
goes yeah it makes the funny noise I
think that black panther could have used
a little bit of [ __ ] flavor but no
they had some flowers comedy like
comedic relief in there the the
um I forget any of these characters
names but they at one point encounter
this student at MIT who has built a
device that can detect vibranium and she
kind of plays the comic relief as she is
sucked into the world of wakanda and I
forget the the city's name it was not
Atlantis it was something else that
Neymar presides over as she is
witnessing all of this stuff she's
throwing out kind of like one-liner
jokes here and there none of which I
felt landed yeah yeah yeah I will say my
favorite part of this movie was the
performances I thought all of the acting
in it was [ __ ] outstanding every
every person in it delivered an
incredible [ __ ] performance
unfortunately for me
uh it just kind of fell flat it was two
hours and 40 minutes long much too long
in my opinion and we are now at a point
with special effects where there's
nothing that is interesting anymore in
my opinion uh all of the action
sequences are things that we've already
seen in every other Marvel movie
yeah I don't know I mean it was like a
good movie it was a solid movie that
isn't enough anymore I think to like
Garner the attention of like holy [ __ ]
that movie was incredible yeah yeah this
is the difference between movies before
and then the movies now you know James
Cameron it I
hey you've worked with him
yeah yeah yeah I'm terminated too and
Terminator one yeah
I well Drew lives hold on a second dude
let me tell you something dude that's
something we came up with on the patreon
a little while back Hulk Hogan uh Hulk
Schwarzenegger anyway you know there's
the unobtainium and then in this one
it's a geranium they're eating what is
the the thing they have to get the blue
thing I forget what it's called like the
heart-shaped flowers yeah yeah yeah yeah
but what is it called this stuff
the flower I don't remember no the blue
stuff oh vibrania yeah vibranium and the
panium these are all different taniums
yeah it's like the tunnels yeah it's
like you know self Tronics I'm [ __ ] up
my [ __ ] is [ __ ] up right give me some
self-tronics but in this yeah and then I
told you no then in this one yes
I'm obtainium and plutonium and then
it's back to the future and it's a
different time dude and you have you
know you know Michael J fox and all
these guys and these are all movie guys
I told you no yeah I told you don't do
it don't do impersonation
of me but the problem is you even have a
big movie like Terminator two yeah
it is not gonna be three hours long it's
two right because
did you think of wakanda though I
thought it was really good up until a
certain point I will say that what was
that point well
so I I went to the movie theater you
know uh don't you see it by the way what
where'd you see it we went to the
Americana the the the military City you
oh you went to Century City that's a
great place to watch it God I hate that
[ __ ] mall
why the parking structure period why
what's wrong with it it's a [ __ ]
nightmare it's gigantic I'm gonna get
lost in there probably 50 of the time I
go there uh you you don't have to listen
every episode of Duty to enjoy but last
week you talked about [ __ ] so I'm
gonna add parking to your list of things
only in Century City why that parking
structure is very poorly designed how
it's just a [ __ ] it's gigantic there
are too many levels there's no Rhyme or
Reason To The Coloring or numbering of
the systems uh all of the signs are
confusing shops this way escalated this
way it's all going in the same place but
the it's just a nightmare and anyone who
lives in L.A will agree with me on this
yeah sure I guess I was there not too
long ago and it rained and I was like
why'd they make this whole thing outside
um
yeah we went to the Americana me and my
wonderful fiance Molly and uh you know
we got some peanut butter I got peanut
butter hi I'm having a stroke I brought
peanut butter in yeah yeah I crouched it
I crouched a [ __ ] jar of Ginger just
selling [ __ ] Jeff up at the front
desk yeah yeah yeah like a hot dog we
also have peanut butter available yeah
you know in the movie theater when you
go in the medical you have to have
traditional foods yeah like peanut
butter with butter on it no I had
popcorn and I got one of those you know
they got the Minute Maid like pop juice
jukebox or something sure oh that Minute
Maid Peach I'm sure you'd [ __ ] all over
that say it's nothing but chemicals now
here's the thing I didn't know that
movie was two and a half hours long or
more 240. right so it was a pack theater
went on Tuesday night and
um
listen I got to tell you something that
I don't know what the what's gonna
happen here but I want to be very
transparent with you there was
um the theater was packed and I was
sitting there Molly was to my right and
to the right of Molly was a woman who
would not stop hacking and coughing and
sneezing oh
yeah and what was that like
it was
it was annoying and wow yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting why is that
interesting it's not very fun to sit
next to somebody who's just hacking and
coughing in your ear the whole uh for an
hour at a time or more you know no I I
understand that yeah
I hear what you're saying but this
person was also sneezing my point is
they were sick
Molly uh and I were both again two hours
and 40 minutes
so Chad I gotta I gotta confess
something to you yeah I think I know
where it's going
he left what at what scene did you leave
in do you remember I just remember the
the uh it was after
she was like well this lady I'm like and
you know you're in a movie theater you
can't be like hi don't be the you know
it's the it's the Dilemma you face
whenever I start having a real hacking
fit for some reason you go well I'm just
not going to interrupt them and say
please don't have bodily functions Chad
you understand that a body exists
unfortunately yeah right unfortunately
for you because you you would like to be
nothing but a ball of thought floating
around uh never having to sleep eat [ __ ]
or park at the Century City Mall however
that's right this person was was a
little sickly uh poor gal and so you
know it's like we got you left how much
of it did you see about an hour uh I
said okay yeah let's go let's just watch
the next uh action scene and maybe I can
uh fool Chad and uh and doozy right yeah
did you get to the point of Namor
attacking wakanda
no I don't know who that is uh what got
to the point where I don't know what all
the names are dude I know the villain of
the movie did you ever see him Michael B
Jordan no what
Namor the guy with the the the the
fluttery Feats yes yeah I saw him I saw
him at the lake with um okay whatever
the [ __ ] they're in the water and how
did you get in here and Angela Bassett
right right and then I saw a couple more
scenes with him I saw the action
sequence where what's her face takes on
a bunch of them yeah uh on a bridge
somewhere and then I think I was at the
point after the action scene where the
MIT student has the motorcycle yes or
the thing that she flies around the Iron
Man suit and what's her face has the
motorcycle and
um uh Angela bezud has the other thing
well that happens before the fight on
the bridge okay so then I also saw the
fight okay all right so I'm sorry I I
think that in certain situations you
have to exhibit your free will which is
something that I talk about a lot on
duty even though dude's interesting you
think that's free will
yeah you could have also chosen to stay
there
yeah and that's free but instead you
were forced out of the movie theater by
your fear of the sick woman
well it was beer controlled you and took
away your agency if you believe you
haven't
and you're really getting in the weeds
here Chad no I don't think that that's
true I think that I just decided I know
you don't but you're you're you dig into
a level of free will
excuse me that
that you you think is it's not about
it's not fear I understand what your
response uh what what responses are or
as you like to say religion was was
essentially born you could make an
argument that it was created when one
cell was like oh I like I want to go to
this light and the devil is here's this
thing that's going to eat me and as our
brains develop we have uh kind of I mean
I don't I don't know that I exactly said
any of that but I get what you're saying
what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is the lady was hacking
and coughing which was which was you
know I don't know if it was rude or she
just had a legitimate little coughing
fit maybe she was uh doing a podcast
maybe she was doing a podcast and she
had a sip from a big old drink they're
about this big at the movie theaters
nowadays hmm
and a little water went down the wrong
end and then she coughed but she was
also sneezing
so we exercised our Free Will and left
and I'm sorry oh I'm so sorry dizzy I
didn't do exactly what you think but I
but doozy is
look dudese and I have a you know I
believe there's uh more of an
understanding there because as we've
gone Along on this show I want to shake
your hand and all that stuff Tootsie and
I have bled together and this is just a
Podcast chat and it was freeing for me
to say sweetie pie
let's leave then we walked around the
mall and we had a good time but are you
curious at all about the end of the
movie two thumbs up wakanda forever two
thumbs up if it's an hour long are you
curious at all about how it ended or
anything yeah a little bit I guess you
could you want to give that away here
well I mean I don't even think it's a
surprise the princess becomes the next
Black Panther oh that's cool she figures
out a way scientifically to synthesize
the plant that all the Black Panthers
have eaten before her that give you
basically the powers it allows you to go
to the spirit realm see the ancestors
and they give you some kind of a sacred
Boon I mean this is like the uh
traditional
Hero's Epic Journey where you have to go
to the underworld and come back with a
sacred Moon that allows you to defeat
whatever the enemy is that's the version
of it in Black Panther it's very similar
to uh like when Luke Skywalker went back
to Dagobah and had the vision of seeing
Darth Vader and then his face gets cut
off and it's him that was his sacred
Moon you understand you're saying that
it's basically the same as every other
[ __ ] sci-fi movie you do this thing
the Epic Heroes flower you have a
classic story structure the remulet I
can't get through the bombula bomb door
use the regible key now you're in there
two thumbs up two thumbs up oh they're a
Ghibli moving on
black panther three the regible
key hi my name is Gerald rigibli
you exercised your free will and I want
you to know that's okay we're friends
oh that's nice see
here's what you do
please
[Music]
please tell the president